hello went to welcome to this video okay
I'm kind of nearing the 2200 more really
have to make sure that is not going to
happen yeah yeah anyway it isn't it's
really looking at readings it's not a
good doesn't help let's say what I'm
trying to say you need to play better
than your rating we will improve on its
own accord okay so this is a sideline of
the way Jim isn't Bishop g4 interesting
here for my D for playing young one
wonder do I never played them before hmm
that's interesting
a 94 it's not enough compensation I
think I can take maybe I should just do
this take then 94 kind of keep it simple
and then c6 you know that wasn't the
most ambitious way of playing with
cannot be possibly bad okay midas good d
for that will probably be exchanged hmm
yeah a5 before that doesn't lead to
anything maybe I can prepare some f5
or just this one yeah it's have equal
it's tough to do something active
something constructive here gaining
space with d 4 gives him yeah much more
scope okay going back here never going
to play a five year anyway
okay fairly equal rook a 6mm
and this is winning a pond I'm not sure
if it's helping that much probably still
what I should do pawn takes our politics
actually Queen takes is interesting I
part XD for Queen takes you for mmm it's
not okay so what now takes on a d3 looks
normal yeah I guess so I mean winning a
pawn why not still it's not easy because
he's got this diagonal working fun and
c6 is attacked I'm not sure if I'm
actually better than this position no
it's not it's not Lydia before he also
has Queen to g7 threatening Queen f7
those kind of technical tricks
hmm and he is threatening c6
yeah I know maybe for I can get be to
hear so Queen d7 threatens Queen f7 so I
have to react to this somehow I was
actually thinking just age 6 I can still
take be too and I have greenie 183 those
kind of things many blended to you for
porn that is active enough
hmm what is he doing here it's got a
couple of ideas I mean yeah this is the
this is a simple more I can take be to
now on this III business to try to get
near his King I mean he has a hard time
to cover this anyway so let's go here
cannot go see three are the b3 is
hanging if he takes I'm checking on you
want and then basically claiming that
check in his King is not very secure
yeah this is a pretty decent spot ferd
yeah I can just take here now right i
think i'm going to do that
he always has enough here for the polar
I think I mean is having all this
pressure on f7 yeah
getting a little bit of an additional
cover and queen have one yeah okay we
never won you covered this is
unprotected hmm seems I cannot do much
time warning
I don't really see a good move him to be
perfectly honest
it's looking at age five as well but
check yeah okay
this is not really a big issue and now I
can give it check in check yeah what
about this
I don't see anything here it looks crazy
to put the cue on g4 bit maybe I
everything's cool if I'm even this you
can afford unbelievable check check
check check add those games are
cleansing I mean he goes to g4 and
there's no chicken 8 I mean okay I
didn't see a check mate check it's
probably my own problem check check
black forfeits on time and the way I'm
playing I really lose every game this is
great so okay so he blundered the fault
poem but he got compensation out of it
yeah yeah this is not easy I mean he's
got this act of PCM the rook is also
potentially active this is not not a
clear clear thing I mean check can you
should check first check yeah of course
I should check first because he cannot
go there again because of this i'm just
playing an idiot it's just a lot a lot
better of course check and everything
was checks in until this just isn't a
good at all can i go here for this
engine says this is saving which is kind
of funny that this actually is not
losing from what Jackie I just took
which is such as bad but still I think
it's okay here it could have killed me
with Roxy aid check because this is
winning okay so we went here check check
and now I don't have a win yeah they're
the computer doesn't see how it now we
played this and again I don't have a
when you're like h5 it's not winning you
amazing okay and now I nice the paw down
yeah strange games strange games I mean
I plane just like a check like really
really badly this is easy i just check
first and I means you hell not do this
this is check this out not going to
check not going to work yeah until I
mean yeah rook c8 also spinning I should
go here which is equal according to the
computer I mean with this King position
white shouldn't be be better ever now I
don't know just playing just making far
too many mistakes you okay well thanks
for watching